>> Dana: THAT’S TELLING.
THANK YOU.
>> CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS HERE AND
KNOW WHO IS PATIENT ZERO.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
IT COULD HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Bill: SUSPICIONS GROWING
ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF COVID AND
POSSIBLE LINKS FROM LAB IN
WUHAN, CHINA.
A GROUP OF REPUBLICANS
DEMANDING ANSWERS CONCERNING
RESEARCH POSSIBLY FUNDED BY THE
U.S.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON IS ONE OF
THE LAWMAKERS LEADING THAT
EFFORT.
WHY HAS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
TAKEN A SUDDEN INTEREST IN THE
LAB LEAK STORY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, ONE OF THEIR
OWN FINALLY ISSUED AND WROTE A
VERY IMPORTANT ARTICLE.
NICKLAUS WADE A FORMER "NEW
YORK TIMES" SCIENCE REPORTER
LAID OUT THE CASE FOR A LAB
SOURCE OF THIS VIRUS.
SO NOW ALL OF A SIGNED IT’S
ACCEPTABLE.
THE EVIDENCE OF THE LEAKING OF
A LAB -- FROM A LAB HAS BEEN
HIDDEN IN PLAIN SIGHT FOR
MONTHS.
BUT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WON’T
PICK UP THE STORY.
DR. FAUCI DISMISSED IT AND
RIDICULED IT.
SO I THINK A GROUP OF SENATORS
AND MIKE GALLAGHER AS WELL IN
THE HOUSE WE WANT HONEST AND
COMPLETE ANSWERS FROM DR. FAUCI
AND DR. COLLINS.
>> Bill: WHEN FAUCI WAS ASKED
ABOUT IT A FEW DAYS AGO HE
SEEMED TO SUGGEST THAT EVERY
THEORY IS STILL ALIVE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
COMMENT?
>> HE IS FINALLY BEING HONEST.
BUT HE WAS DISMISSIVE A YEAR
AGO.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHY.
WHY DID HE DISMISS SOMETHING SO
OBVIOUS AND ASK THE MEDIA WHY
DID THEY VILIFIED PEOPLE LIKE
SENATOR COTTON WHO CAME OUT AND
RELAYED WHAT WAS AN OBVIOUS
TRUTH.
THIS IS A POSSIBILITY.
>> Bill: FAUCI AS CORRECT QUOTE
I’M NOT CONVINCED.
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE.
POMPEO WAS ASKED THE QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL EVER
KNOW HERE HE IS.
>> THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN EARLY
JANUARY OF 2020 WHEN WE WERE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
PRECISELY WHAT WAS ABOUT TO HIT
THE WORLD AND THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY HAD GONE
COMPLETELY DARK.
THEY WOULDN’T TAKE PHONE CALLS
OR ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS.
WE SENT INQUIRIES.
WE COULDN’T GET A STRAIGHT
ANSWER.
AMBASSADOR COULDN’T GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER.
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY KNEW
THEY HAD A PROBLEM AND DIDN’T
WANT THE WORLD TO KNOW IT AND
THEY STILL KNOW THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM AND DON’T BECAUSE US TO
KNOW.
>> WILL WE EVER KNOW, SENATOR?
LET’S HOPE SO.
WE NEED THE FULL STORY AS WELL.
WE’RE ASKING N.I.H. DIRECTOR
COLLINS TO TELL US MORE ABOUT
THIS GAIN OF FUNCTION PAUSE AND
ALSO THE EXCEPTION FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS AND REASONS.
SO WE ASK SOMETHING LIKE 17
QUESTIONS THAT REALLY GETTING
TO THE HEART OF THE ISSUE IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HEALTH AGENCIES
FUNDED IN TERMS OF GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH CREATING
VIRUSES AND HOW WE COOPERATED
WITH DR. XI WHO WORKED AT THE
WUHAN LAB.
ALL THIS HAS BEEN AVAILABLE FOR
MONTHS.
THE EVIDENCE HAS BEEN HIDDEN IN
PLAIN SIGHT.
THE MEDIA DIDN’T WANT TO PICK
IT UP AND DR. FAUCI HASN’T
WANTED THE TALK ABOUT IT.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT IT HE USES
CERTAIN PHRASES AND IT
INCREASES MY CURIOSITY.
>> Bill: A WEEK AGO WHEN YOU
HAD THE BACK AND FORTH WITH
RAND PAUL FAUCI SUGGESTED THERE
WAS NO U.S. MONEY THAT WENT
TOWARD GAIN OF FUNCTION.
DID HE NOT SAY THAT IN THE BACK
AND FORTH?
>> AGAIN, IT WAS A VERY LOYALLY
RESPONSE.
YOU HAVE TO PARSE HIS WORDS
VERY CAREFULLY.
OUR LETTER IS DESIGNED TO NOT
ALLOW THEM TO PARSE THEIR WORDS
ANYMORE.
WE’RE ASKING STRAIGHT UP
QUESTIONS.
I HOPE THEY ANSWER THEM
HONESTLY AND COMPLETELY.
I AM ALSO HOPING THE
INVESTIGATIVE MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS ALSO LOOK INTO THIS AND
START ASKING THE SAME QUESTIONS.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON TODAY.
WE SHALL CONTINUE TO ASK THE